anatomically modern human beings have
been on this planet for roughly 200 000
years and even though that's a small
fraction of the amount of time the earth
has been around which is over 4 billion
years on a human scale it's an
incredibly long amount of time just to
put it in perspective if this is present
times if you wanted to put when was the
roman empire well if you're talking
about about 2 000 years ago it would
show up on our timeline right about
right about there if you wanted to talk
about when the pyramids were constructed
it would be right about there you can
hardly see the time difference between
now and several thousand years ago if
you want to see how long we've had
writing about 5 000 years is our current
best estimate once again it barely shows
up on this timeline how long have we had
agriculture well 10 to 15 000 years once
again it's a small fraction of this
another way to think about it think
about all of our ancestors the various
generations that have passed since the
first immersion of
the first the first appearance of
anatomically modern human beings
this is over six or seven thousand
generations into the past think about
all of the stories that must have
happened a lot of simple things it might
be a founding of a village a a
a killing of an animal a
very simple
courtship a tenderness between a mother
and their child and think about the big
things the wars the battles the natural
disasters it's hard for us to imagine
how much has occurred even in the last
100 or two hundred or thousand years
much less two hundred thousand years
but we seek to understand regardless and
that is what history is all about
and as we'll see history is in general
trying to understand the stories of our
past and if we want to get a little bit
more technical we can also think about
pre-history which is technically the
things that happened before we had
writing
because
writing is our main tool for history
what i have right over here this picture
this is egyptian hieroglyphs and
egyptian hieroglyphs are over 5 000
years old i could write 5 000 years
before the present but even when you
have writing it's not enough as we'll
see not only in this video but in many
videos as we study history and world
history it's really a lot of science and
a lot of detective work to make sense of
what has happened and that understanding
will constantly evolve for example we
didn't know what these hieroglyphs said
until
when
we found the rosetta stone and what was
useful about the rosetta stone is that
they had
they had some text written in the
hieroglyphs and they had the same text
then written in a greek that we were
able to understand and that started to
help unlock what these hieroglyphs said
but even once you have a sense of what
they say and even if you understand it
quite well you still have to do a lot of
detective work and take everything with
a grain of salt you can imagine if
one
if there's a bunch of groups of people
here and we get the history from
this group for some reason we're able to
find what they wrote
well it might not be completely unbiased
they might have a negative view of this
group or that group and so you have to
take it with all the grain of salt at
the extreme form they might have
eliminated some of these groups and then
only they were around to say what
actually happened you also have to be
skeptical because you don't know whether
these stories are actual accounts or
whether someone just made it up to fit a
world view you also have to keep in mind
that these stories whether they were
transmitted written or orally their past
they're often times re-transmitted from
generation to generation and especially
in the oral case but even in the written
you gotta wonder what's added over each
generation you can imagine people
embellishing making the story a little
bit better or taking out things of the
story that really doesn't fit in with
their world view
so even when we have the writing and
this is once again some images of early
writing this is the famous sumerian
cuneiform there's a sumerian
uniform tablet here even when we have it
obviously we have much much more writing
as we get to the more recent past we
have to be very very very skeptical we
know today even if two observers
observed something yesterday you know
something that just happened they might
have very very different perceptions of
what happened so even though there's
writing we have to be skeptical but
things get in some ways even more
interesting before we have writing when
we go into prehistory you might wonder
how do we know anything about what
happened if there's no written accounts
well that's where the science and we get
even more detective work for example
this is a neanderthal skull and the type
of people the scientists that will study
this you'll hear terms like
anthropologists
or anthropology this is a study of
present and past humans in human society
and then a subset of anthropology which
is really delving into
pre-history and even history itself is
archaeology
which is the subset of anthropology that
focuses on the past study of humans in
human society and they're mainly going
to do it through remains now there's
other fields you might associate the
term of the field of paleontologist
paleo
paleonto paleontologist
antallo
an antal
logie
paleontology
you might associate this with things
like dinosaur bones but there their
techniques are also useful for
old human remains or even pre-human
remains and so it might inform
archaeology and anthropology so for
example an archaeologist might unearth
this neanderthal skull they will use
some science in order to figure out when
was this when did the skull enter into
the ground they might use a technique
like radiocarbon dating
radio
carbon
dating
which could be used for things up to
around 50 000 years old so around
that time span on our timeline and it's
based on this idea that you have this
atmospheric carbon 14
that actually comes from
nitrogen 14 that gets
between interactions with the solar wind
and these cosmic particles becomes this
radioactive carbon 14
and that carbon 14 which can become part
of carbon dioxide incorporated into
plants through photosynthesis which then
get eaten into animals so while
something is living they will have a
certain amount of carbon 14 in their in
their tissue but then once they die
they're not longer adding more carbon
carbon-14 and the carbon-14 decays into
the more stable carbon-12 and so based
on the ratio between the carbon-14 to
the carbon-12 and it takes roughly 5000
years
5730 years to be exact for roughly half
of the carbon 14 to decay to carbon-12
so based on this ratio and i go into
much more detail in other videos you can
figure out how old these things are and
you get reasonably precise within a
couple of a hundred hundreds of years if
you want to go further into the past
there's things like
there's things like potassium argon
dating which is once again taking a
radio active form of potassium
and using the idea that it decays into
into argon and that when a vault when a
volcano releases the argon
in that rock is able to go into the
atmosphere but then once it hardens you
have the decay and so you can see how
long since that volcanic eruption
do are we looking at and so for example
you can dig you can do
stratigraphic techniques right over here
stratigra stratigraphy have trouble
saying these words that's looking at the
various layers of the earth and you
might use some dating techniques for
example potassium argon say okay this is
that a certain amount of age that is a
certain amount of age these were maybe
do this was volcanic rock from a
volcanic eruption and then you can look
at the fossils you could say okay a
fossil that i found here is going to be
newer than the stuff here and it's going
to be older than the stuff here and this
might be the newest of all so you can
look at relative dating and if you're
lucky enough to have some volcanic rock
you could do some of this potassium
argon dating and there's many many many
other techniques
and it isn't just about saying oh this
skull wasn't this place in the world at
this time you can start to infer other
things you can look for fossils of the
type of animals the type of plants near
these burial sites you could see how
dense these burial sites were what type
of cultures were there you could start
to make inferences you can try to infer
how these people died you might have
some trauma fractures here and you might
say okay that was the violent death you
might look at their teeth to think about
the type of things they might have eaten
or their general health you might look
at the tools that are buried near them
this right over here these are
paleolithic uh arrow i guess spearheads
or tools right over here paleolithic is
defined by more of these harder edges
you have neolithic tools which have more
of these smoother edges than old stone
age new stone age right over here and by
looking at all of that you have all of
these scientists you have these
anthropologists archaeologists
paleontologists who are starting to
piece together prehistory and sometimes
these techniques are done together
sometimes we have writing and we have
these techniques to try to get a more
complete picture
now i want to end with just a note of
caution
even though we have all of these
techniques and we're learning more every
day our understanding of all that has
happened is very very incomplete
and even more it constantly gets
challenged the more we learn there are
things that
very serious people believed 50 or 100
years ago that we have now proven to be
false and things that we now take very
seriously it's likely that in 50 or 100
years people might prove some of that
wrong so history even though it's about
the past it is constantly evolving we're
constantly learning more and we should
have a a very solid humility about what
we know and what we don't know